bueno específicamente esta ha sido una
de las explicaciones más contundentes
que ha ofrecido también el presidente de
la república ante la pregunta de que si
el ejecutivo nacional ya tenía el
control de los centros carcelarios él ha
dicho que me gustaría decir lo que sí
pero no puedo asegurarlo esto da cuenta
de la grave crisis carcelario de solo
porque se ha denunciado en los últimos
tres años la falta de recursos el
ejecutivo nacional ha tenido que acudir
a reuniones con gobiernos extranjeros
para pedir asesoría ha reconocido
también que debe realizarse una
inversión cuantiosa superior a los 74
millones de dólares sólo en el centro de
penitenciario guayaquil se requieren por
lo menos una inversión de 24 millones de
dólares y ha sido en este donde el
presidente de la república ha dicho que
comenzará una infraestructura una
inversión en infraestructura y en
seguridad carcelaria y esto también
requiere una medida para inmediatamente
el estado de excepción requerir que se
extienda por los próximos 60 días
también se ha dicho que se requiera la
suspensión del derecho a la
inviolabilidad de la correspondencia
también a la limitante de la reunión de
los distintos presos un caso que se va
actualizando conforme pasa el tiempo